[Music]
let's go out to Columbia South Carolina
and talk to the great Haley what's up
Haley hey guys how's it going we're
partying what about
you I almost partying I haven't
graduated yet but I'm about to excellent
excellent what's
up so due to me about to graduate taking
board exams move out and move on with my
life in
general I'm finding that there are
certain Financial expectations or habits
from my family okay um in response to me
putting up certain boundaries that are
not going so well wait let me back out a
little bit so you're taking boards what
are you taking boards
for um to become a clinical data analyst
wow very cool and then you're still
living at
home yes I did during graduate school to
try to save on cost excellent and that
cost you in your soul right it it it did
it really did so um are
you are you first Jen are you the first
one in your family to quote unquote make
it get
out I would technically be the second
second okay but is not common at all but
you're living at home and so are you
working through grad
school I am okay so the expectation is
oh miss Richie Rich you're going to pay
for us and our bills and
everything or you have the funds to do
so so why not oh that makes even worse
that makes it a oh you have this so if
you don't do it you're holding out on us
you don't love us you don't care about
what happens to us gosh dude that that's
one of my very very I have very few
triggers that make me just insta angry
that's one of them oh my gosh somebody's
trying to make their life better and the
old world that they come from just
throws every hook they have into their
just bare flesh to hold you back oh my
gosh okay so how can I
help um I've the like I said the
reallocating funds is the easy part for
me um I'm still trying to deal with the
emotional aftermath of saying no to
things or saying that I can't do x y and
z
um I the amount of and you probably hear
it all the time but the amount of guilt
that weighs on
me
is painful in the sense I start second
guessing and doubting
myself um
of wow okay I'm I I keep trying not to
get upset when I say these
things it would be really strange if you
were able to say these things and not
get
upset if here's
why I want nothing more in the
world than my son and my
daughter to have a more whole healthier
life than me
and that's across a
spectrum I hope that they have a more
grounded spiritual life than I did I was
such a chaotic mess I have been I
probably still
am I hope that they don't have the same
demons when it comes to the person they
see in the mirror
physically I hope that financially that
money for them is an opportunity to
serve and help and love and bring joy
and to themselves and to their families
and to their communities and not this
thing that just ravages their soul like
I want their the lives to be better than
what I've got and I've got it pretty
good and every parent I know wants that
it's the those other
parents and brothers and sisters I've
got brothers and sisters and cousins and
they are rooting for me like you
wouldn't
believe and you have the
opposite you have people that are are
connecting themselves to you so that
they can drag you back so that you can
fund
their desire to not work or their lack
of or their whatever and so what you're
experiencing is not the way it should be
and if it shouldn't be that way your
body should try to get your attention to
help make it right and so if you're able
just to be like oh yeah and then my mom
and dad and then my cousins then my
sister and brother whatever if you're
able to just rattle that off you've
detached from reality and a pretty
significant way so I want to tell you I
think your emotions are right they feel
whole to
me okay you're not
crazy so what is guilt tell me about
this
guilt um this is actually a question I
thought about multiple times and I'm
just now I guess accepting reality of
the
situation
um and that being not from the most
affluent background and or
childhood
that I felt as though I was kind of a
burden um and using resources whether it
be
financially all the upkeeps that it
takes to have a child in the first place
um so I found that I where did that come
from did they tell you that for that did
they tell you that
or did you create that or was it kind of
in the
air it was I
I not g to put this uh the more involved
I got into family finances from a very
young age the more aware I guess it
became of how much I cost as far as um
activities I wanted to do or be a part
of
or um you know we have to pay for her
books so we can't get X Y and Z and I
just yeah that is so manipulative and
gross it's gross that they did that to
you you're there kid you're you're here
because
of something they did not
you right and all kid kids want and
desire and seek experiences and want to
be with their friends and want to try
things out it's the parents job to look
at reality finances and to say hey we're
not going to be able to do that we're
going to do this or in this house we're
not going to do that we're going to go
do
this it's never okay for a parent to say
yeah cool we'll we'll let you play
soccer and I guess uh I just won't go I
won't do anything fun for the next six
months cuz it's all about you huh
kid
and you learn at a really young
age that that burdensome question you
asking like oh my Dad's life would be
better if I wasn't
here my mom's life would be more joyful
because she would have more resources if
I wasn't around and what you learn to do
I'm guessing is squash the things that
made you happy or that you wanted to
like go
explore whether it was sports or
instruments or friends or going to a
birthday party across town or whatever
the thing
was cuz usually in these situations it
starts out as money but it ends up as I
don't want to have to drive you I've
been working all day or you're just
going to sit there on the couch while
I'm off working and you're not going to
do anything to contribute around here
right yes sir that sound
familiar yes sir yeah and then somehow
some
way you were born of something different
you had a fire inside of you you said
I'm getting out of
here and this nonsense stops with
me and what they don't tell you in the
Instagram posts and they don't tell you
in grad school which I wish they
would is you don't get off scotf free it
hurts and when you pull away from those
hooks that people have stuck in your
back and in your skin and your legs it
rips your skin it burns it hurts you
bleed
so I guess what I'm trying to tell you
is the guilt yeah man your two parents
should be rooting for you in such a such
a they should be your number one fanatic
cheerleaders they shouldn't be
vampires and so with like pulling away
from that yeah guilt is normal it's
right you're not crazy because you feel
guilty
you're not even crazy if you go out on
your own and you get stable and you cut
them off for a
season as part of forming
boundaries and they've probably told you
you'll never make it without them is
that
true or but
I into terms it's it's more so of I
guess it's a generational thing to have
unspoken of of I help to get you where
you are therefore it's like a more so
treated like a give and take transaction
rather than being yeah like you're some
kind of 401k for them
right yeah honestly me off point that's
feels like like hey we like we've been
keeping numbers and here's how much
we've invested in you so this is what
you owe us at 12% return Hey listen
Haley that is absolute stonemad bull
crap it's ridiculous
ulous and if they were your financial
adviser I would tell you to fire
them because they're not telling you the
truth but this is more complex because
it's Mom and Dad it's
family and I'm going to tell you the
same thing you need to fire them you
need to walk
away do you have another um and I'm not
saying Forever by the way I'm not one of
those guys like you cut ties and never
come at um for whatever reason they've
created the world they've created and
I'm sure if went back in their histories
they've had a pretty chaotic life is
that
fair that's fair yeah it's not an excuse
but it gives a context right um right do
you have a group of people that you've
met like in grad school that are all
Haley all the
time I have or I do have friends who um
honestly are the ones who tell me like
this is complete in ut BS and of
course I to absolve myself of guilt
which I had to recognize and don't
absolve it don't absolve It abve soul
don't absolve it head right into it
don't run from
guilt guilt is
right it's your body trying to reconcile
all the nonsense and reality it's your
body trying to reconcile hey we're doing
a thing we were told not to do and what
you have to do is hold that thing at
arms length and say hey is this
true because some guilt is right you
know what I mean and some if you if you
just went to your mom and just were
super disrespectful and ugly like I
can't believe you're terrible mom yeah
you should feel guilty because that's
not
cool it's dishonoring to speak to your
mom that way but creating boundaries
that keep your you safe and keep you
whole and allow you to go do this
amazing job and to create this new life
that is going to be free from poverty
and free from making the kids drive the
wagon instead of the adults in the world
Drive the wagon um yeah you get to set
some pretty boundaries
there and your mom and dad can gravy
train you all they want they can 401K
you and you owe us that you don't owe
them anything
Financial zero none unless y'all came up
with some agreement you'll pay back grad
school or something but I have a strong
suspicion that they did not pay for your
grad
school or college now or anything that's
right how much do you owe are you in the
hole after this
um I was at least um well before the end
of college it was covid um so I was
paused at around
80,000 good gosh for undergrad and
beginning of grad um I've what do you ow
now been making payments during the
pause and down to Le 60 good for you
good for you all right here's the deal
I'm just going to make the a
mathematical equation okay okay you are
underwater you have absolutely no
business trying to bail somebody else's
boat get the water out of their boat
because yours is sinking yours is
underwater
too right and this is not about guilt
this is just math you have no business
bailing somebody else out until at least
you're above
water and so if you're working on
practicing building uh practicing
boundaries I want you to start there hey
guys I am
$80,000 $60,000 in the whole I'm not
sending any money to anybody other than
Sally May other than to the government
to get these loans taken care of y'all
are on your
own do you still live at
home apparently yes when do you move
out applications where I've submitted
single lease applications those get
taken up from January February what does
that
mean um that means that they reviewed my
application and once someone moves out
I'm on a wait list to basically take
their place in a in a campus residence
hall it's equivalent upper class living
yes okay what about an apartment often
apartments are way cheaper because you
have to pay for the board plan I've also
put in applications for apartments and I
want here's my deal on a wait list for
January I want you out before January I
want you out before the
holidays I want you out as soon as
possible if January has to be January
cool but I want you to really quickly
like we're recording this at the very
beginning of November I want you to like
within the week put some very clear
boundaries on the presents you will not
be buying for the adults you want to buy
something for your nieces and nephews
fine
hey this year guys I'm pay I'm focused
wholly on starting this new career and
getting myself out of $60,000 in debt
every extra Penny I have will be going
towards that so I want everyone to know
I'm not buying a bunch of presents this
year I'm not and when you do that I want
you to just take your hand and put it on
your chest and I want you to feel that
guilt because it's going to be heavy
feel it breathe through
it
until your body lets it run go for a
walk and ask yourself why you're walking
because I know that you're
brilliant hey is this guilt right is it
my job to make sure my the adults in my
life have a thank Christmas no it's not
have I worked really hard and I'm
blessed to make a good salary yeah and
right now that salary goes to paying off
the investment the debts I took out on
myself not making sure other people have
momentary glips of
of hooray and by the way their 401K
investment in you is twofold number one
it's Financial you owe us no you
freaking
don't number two it's also um cultural
they are going to walk around with their
chest puffed out look what we did for
our
baby they didn't do anything you did in
fact you've been propping them up for a
long long
time
a long time they say that poverty is a
mindset it's not a financial number and
this is one of the ways it traps
you because here's what's going to
happen if you don't if you don't make a
clean break now what you're going to end
up doing is cosigning on a car loan
because one of their cars is going to
bust or you're going to cosign on a loan
to fix the air conditioner the heater
because it's going to break you're still
going to be 60,000 in the hole and then
you're going to need to come up with the
money for the first and last months
whatever and that's going to put you a
little bit deeper and you're going to
end up with a job paying 100,000 bucks
and you're going to owe
$125,000
instantly and you will then
self-perpetuate this same crisis the
difference is you're going to do what I
did which was I wasn't never in poverty
but we did not have a lot growing up we
had very very little in fact it's a
shock to our friends and Neighbors how
little we
had
but when I went and got my fancy degree
I spent like crazy and I ended up
digging a bigger hole than my family
could have ever my parents could have
ever dug because they didn't have the
access to that kind of
money but the more the more sour you
make sometimes and the higher your um
degree stature the more the banks will
just willy-nilly loan you and I'd ended
up in a bigger
hole so why' I tell you all that Break
Free
choose freedom and I'm glad you've got
some friends I want you to reach out to
them I also want you to reach out to the
College Counseling Center and say hey
I'm going ready to to make some pretty
significant changes in my life I want to
practice some of this well yall walk
alongside me you don't need to go to a
Counseling Center because you're
deficient or broken or have some sort of
disorder I want you to go use the
counseling resources at the school that
you pay for by the way um they're baked
into your your tuition and fees I want
you to go and practice some of these
conversations practice telling your mom
and dad hey no more money this this
Christmas um January I'm out December
15th I'm moving out and I love you guys
but it's time for me to to do on my
own and by the way you're not doing it
on your own you're inviting friends
you're going to bring that Community
super close weekly dinners weekly
laundry parties weekly whatever study
parties your place your place your
place this is building something
completely new I'm proud of you Haley
and don't discount the hurt this will
hurt along the way and I think that hurt
is
right you're you're making a whole new
family tree I'm proud of
you